topic
we must discuss we've talked about ali
wong this week or the past few weeks but
ali wong
after eight years of marriage
is getting a divorce
yeah man
um i i am not
i'm surprised but i'm not that surprised
yeah i mean everything i've read that it
was amicable and they're still going to
be co-parenting and it
um and i also read um i think in her
book she mentions that they did sign a
prenup and whatnot
um but so no more d i haven't heard any
details about the why or how
sure but
i mean we can speculate we're comedians
but that's we're both like you and i are
both married
and
it can be
difficult you know i mean hey just just
do taxes with your spouse and let her
see what comedy
that's all you really need to do uh to
see how your spouse really feels about
all these comedy shows you're doing
oh
but i think i think it is interesting
it's interesting topic yeah for people
who
won or married or wanting to date or
wanting to pursue comedy but also have a
life
i think i've heard i think maybe dan
soder said on the podcast or
one of like one of the new york comics
was like my advice to young comics is
don't date anyone for like the first
five years of comedy or whatever maybe
it was an ape bargain no because he was
dating
someone said don't date because comedy
is your life for a long time so it's a
tough balance you know
and you have kids too
yeah i mean i think
without a doubt the element of ali wong
being super successful
being a female comedian and just being
like and i only want to say female and
just being a comedian at the top of
the game
is going to have challenges
like
for sure in a marriage right yeah i
think it's so fascinating that we've
watched her transition from
each of the specials around like
her at the start of her success her
husband being like the main uh
breadwinner in the family and how that
transitioned to like the her being the
main breadwinner in the family it's you
know it's complicated
you know i've i've been a retired trophy
husband like i was the trophy husband
and then i became like the other side of
it as well so it's
and i'm not anywhere close to ali wong's
like
nowhere close to like what she's pulling
in right but
it's tough because like that shift of
breadwinner-ism
kind of changes you you i mean like it
kind of changes the dynamic
where i would say
where some people aren't like that
comfortable being like
the stay-at-home
dad
you know i mean like
yeah it's not a thing that most people
may like enjoy you i'm saying or they
weren't necessarily expecting it either
but it's also
like the lifestyle of a comedian is not
for everyone like when you're you're on
the road
like
i mean she was doing movies like and
like that's you're not
with that person like that person isn't
there you know what i'm saying like
uh
yeah it's not easy for sure so like the
money can only get you so far it's like
oh you being gone all the time we're
multi-millionaires
but it's also like hey we have two kids
and a family
and like and i'm not speculating what
went wrong with her marriage at all i
just know from personal experience and
friends in this game
that like the light that road life of
always being gone can re at first it's
like yeah i know that's part of the job
but when it becomes reality
there's lonely you know i was in l.a was
supposed to be for a week ended up being
two weeks because i got sick like that's
at a very low level but that's still
randomly in the middle of the month i'm
like i'm gone for two weeks you know
across the country so it's it's it's
difficult
yeah yeah yeah
i mean laying it out to your spouse like
letting them know ahead of time
like before my wife and i before she
even moved down here i was like
i love the idea but just know i'm like
gone like every night like because
here's the thing that yes that's helpful
that's very very helpful
but it reaches a different category
because i don't think allie wong knew
the level of success that she was going
to get to
[Music]
you know
like
and now not that she's not deserving of
it like she deserves all of it and she's
very skilled it's just like
that
when those i mean i don't know i i feel
like
when you get to like seven eight
figures
the game changes son yeah yeah yeah i'm
excited to find out
[Laughter]
it just it just changes and so like but
also the expectations and so like
you gotta be so established like in the
marriage and
i think that's the other thing is like
kids also complicated and then the
rearing of the kids
and it's like
well
where to your point where is daddy going
also where's mommy going if mommy's the
comedian
doing all the comedy like work like ally
wong like you just never know i mean and
again we're all speculating here
but
we kind of
there's without a doubt obviously
something went wrong in the marriage and
i have a hard time believing that comedy
was not a factor yeah
yeah yeah
so i think for people oh and we have uh
za from malaysia in here yo this is sick
yo thank you everyone for watching and
hanging out and tuning in here um
so yeah i think i think so some people
may be watching this and are like
all right i'm married how can i how can
i balance comedy in marriage or i'm
dating or i'm thinking about dating it's
like i think for me
i think it's
what just being transparent with your
significant other
like being transparent this is just the
reality this is my i love doing this
this is my job or i aspire to make this
my job these are the sacrifices and also
i think
like ahead of time getting that out in
front and then checking in and like
being like
how is this going for you i was just
gone for a week like how like really
keeping an open line of communication
not taking it personally but also having
to understand
what we do as comedians
is not normal
it's not like you know me i remember
early on driving 12 hours for like 50
bucks you know
for like 20 minutes and bombing not
bombing but for 12 hour drive it was a
bomb i will say that's not normal and
it's hard for people to understand
with a 401k and like
a job like people
it's hard for them to understand and
grasp it so it's it's important to have
an open line of communication
at all times about
game changer it's the being honest about
okay how is it how's it going now
and like what are you doing
to make this work i mean i know i went
to a period where
i was doing it like
every other night and then i had to
check in
and the reality was like yo
i need you at the house more nights and
i was like all right how could i do more
on the nights that i'm
doing comedy and so i try to like pack
it in it's like and it became three open
mics a night rather than three nights a
week it was like how can i pack in
these this this time
um
and so yeah i think it's just important
to have that open line of communication
and know that yeah it's gonna change
because you know your spouse changed
your life changes like i mean there was
a time when i was like yo babe
i'm going full time in this and i was
like a year in oh and that was a bad
time to go full time into this right but
she was so supportive right and then
like the reality sort of checked in like
i'm not even good at this yet i'm just
starting this and so like just making
sure that
that open line of communication is there
is very helpful
i agree yeah and um
abby i hope i'm saying that right ab
here abby let me know
um this is their first time tuning in so
thank you um
but uh they say i think it boils down to
your own time management my girlfriend
has been super supportive of my comedy
but when it's our time i better be
paying full attention and i i'm mindful
that as well that it is like
when i'm with family i'm a hundred
percent there i'm not
like creating content
like i am with there so your sign says
be intentional be present
yeah
yeah man like that's so key is that when
you're doing family time
be there when you're doing comedy be
there
like yeah and all like just yeah don't
don't be like hey babe uh i got this
joke
while you're having dinner
like
some other kind of stuff not that that
doesn't come up but like
be there like if it's a joke about
something you're talking about then
that's okay but like don't be like
all right let me run these bits by you
real quick because i got the set coming
up in a couple of days it's like yo she
doesn't want to hear all that and just
and just like
they support you
support them just as much and whatever
it is they're doing even if they're
talking about something happening at
work listen be there
contribute like
as comedians we can be very selfish and
be like it's us all the time or whatever
but like be sure as much as they support
you to reciprocate that so even when
you're not there they still feel
supported in a part of what you're doing
making them a part of it
is another aspect of it so it's
it's it's really yeah it's unfortunate i
hate i mean you know i've i've gone
through
uh two divorce i haven't been divorced
but like my parents have been divorced
twice
so like i i divorce is no joke and it's
not fun it's not something people
just do on a whim so um i hope the best
for ally
but um yeah it's not a great situation
but hopefully maybe this will bring up
the topic of
like pursuing comedy having like a
healthy work-life balance and just
understanding
like the relationship the life side of
being a comedian that people probably
don't think about but it's it's it's
important and it's tricky
facts
facts nice killer reeves in here what's
goodie fam
oh this is great oh and abby okay it's
abby
awesome
oh and they did um
they were posting photos
because her husband's asian they were
posting photos of her with the wrong
asian guy
apparently there's a hashtag like
wrong asian
that like when people just post the
wrong asians so i think it was
pack
randall pack or something yeah
she did a movie with them she was they
were posting photos of them
they were what she was she she was
she played her
rando pack played her husband
in a movie
and so they put that up as getting
divorced but it's also the wrong asian
right
yeah
oh boy
all right but yeah thank you all for
contributing it as well um
we appreciate y'all's feedback as well
oh and john said her husband gets half
the money right they now they had a
prenup yeah yeah i think prenup was more
on the fact that the husband
wasn't gonna like
i think it was more to protect him
not necessarily to protect her i think
it was a prenup like yo
we're gonna likely just do our own
things because i've got this money saved
up or whatever because he was doing like
super well when they got together but i
i don't know what the prenup says i'm
just thinking like
yo if you had a prenup usually a prenup
means
whatever we make separately in our own
profession we get to keep
yeah so just keep that in mind my
friends in any relationship keep them a
part of your own comedy career
uh as much as they support you support
them and just communication isn't
crucial
get that prenup yeah
oh and ryan hit us with a super chat
let's go
that's the one thing i'm gonna tell my
wife today then i got a super chat you
can't tell me nothing
we made 99 cents today so
we out yeah we made it thank you so much
ryan we do appreciate that